I'm your friend Bryce is single so
that's an option what happened to that
girl I love crazy girls wait you're
still with your girlfriend no I just
learned this right no what happened what
happened God workouts it's hard I've
never lived the one before and it's
tough but what happened leave it that
Bobby it's not everyone's we argued
every day and that's a couple times a
day and didn't work out yeah
Wow living together especially that's
all confines is a ver is very
detrimental to any relation don't care
how much you love somebody just doesn't
work I learned a lot about myself
yeah good I'm glad you did kalila kalila
nah I mean there is there's a little bit
of you can feel there's a little bit of
resentment not resentment but I can tell
when she's in a bad mood where i annoy
or whatever and so you'd have to learn
to kind of you know build your soldier
on and just get through whatever they're
going through you couldn't do that with
this girl like when people say I we
argued kalila and I never argue it's
basically like she's like I'm annoyed or
like no I'm just you know and I can go
I'll just go in the other room then or
like I remember when I said today I go
I'm gonna go play a far cry with Steve
yeah co-op it was a little bit she's
like alright well guess I'll see you
later then no I said I'll see you never
never or whatever our Pacific and that
tone I could tell was like you know I
could go what does that mean how is that
passive-aggressive I was making it very
clear
see you never right
what does that mean would you start a
fight but this is what I do I go I'm
gonna play she goes I'll see you never
then okay I guess you'll never see me Oh
see you never but here you forever yeah
I don't I don't start confrontations
because those feelings subside oh so
you're the hero in this story I'm
definitely the hero oh my god yeah
because because I'm gonna say this right
now out loud and is gonna start a fight
maybe there's nothing
you do that makes me mad oh my god
you're so full there's nothing you could
do that I know he's very classy can I
keep the house clean it doesn't matter
whatever it might be it does it there's
nothing there
oh you're so far I don't know I when's
the last time I was like I met at you
never
you're pretty that's not it that's not
it there are things that I could but I
just don't right so my point is is that
either is really I'm dead honest opinion
and my honest feeling is that there's
nothing but everything that I do annoys
the [ __ ] out of her okay but let me
you're in the past and that's been every
relationship
have you never so you're saying you
could have lived with all of them for no
no so have you ever told them like okay
yeah that annoys me no that's the way
the first relate because there are
things in other relationships I know we
were getting at there's things in the
other relationship that there was
something that was kind of always there
and I always canoe I always knew this
there's a ticking time bomb
on this right and it will go off but
with this there isn't that because we've
it six years almost right but I also
that's kind of scary if you're not
communicating if you're not
communicating to me how you really feel
because I I do it literally is nothing
that you do that makes me mad I'm going
lobster diving good you know I mean I'm
gonna go somewhere with the beach with
it so and so and hike go
you know I'm sleeping early good I'm
doing my own thing I don't give a [ __ ]
it really doesn't bother me but me I'm
playing co-op mode with steve-o Bobby
Bobby Bobby go hike with yeah yeah why I
don't want to go oh yeah yeah it's
always that like if I said to her hey I
have to go to gank Cook's house for a
barbecue and she goes I don't want to go
I'd be like all right don't go yeah but
do I give you grief for ever going
anywhere
but if I don't go somewhere with her and
she wants me to go then that's the where
the grief is yeah but also I don't
restrict your life ever you don't know
you are anytime she's the easiest one in
terms of like you know she really is the
easiest one in terms of like um things
that I can get away with oh my god
that's not good what the hell Bobby what
have you been doing no things I can get
away with like oh I could play so much
more to video games oh you know I can
like you know so mysterious have you
gotten away with party no I've never
you're getting at anything sexual or
than that no right what I'm saying is is
that sleeping even like my brother my
brother you know his fights a lot with
Ayalon he is sleeping like she he will
win every wakes up late it just starts a
fight what time do I wake up today mmm
yeah nothing all my girlfriends that
would be a problem and I think that they
probably had a very good point they
wanted to spend a portion of their day
I'm magical I know I live in the dream I
get it look I'm not saying that I always
had the patience for that and I think
what I Lonnie is going through is
probably what I went through the first
two years in my relationship with you
there's a point at which you just stop
giving a [ __ ] because it's exhausting to
you that's why I told my brother hey
keep doing what you're doing I can't
teach you though should bend
also break big brother Lee just hear me
out Bryce I think I'm I love you come on
babe this is horrible but my point is is
this
what you're doing is the wrong thing
right what you do is this you avoid
those because they're they're
spontaneous and they dissipate what like
little quarrels that people have when
they live with each other like you don't
put the cap on the [ __ ] toothpaste
that bothers me right
I had one girlfriend I did that okay you
can't do that be like what the small
stuff yeah I would just ignore that she
even said that yeah you know why I'm not
like that because I don't like when I'm
being nagged right my mother was a big
nagger every little detail of my room my
life every corner I turned she had
caught like a running commentary so I I
don't like it when people do it to me so
how are the [ __ ] people whatever style
they want to live I don't give a [ __ ] I
have to really look at it objectively
and say you know what that's just how
they do it this is how I do it now if
you encroach on my [ __ ] line I don't
and you [ __ ] up my things
no that's a problem you can go lobster
hunting whatever little adventures that
you want to do do your Laura Croft [ __ ]
like go go in the tomb girl or whatever
you need I'm not doing that well I'm so
happy that you that you want to do it
and I support it I said there's nothing
that you do that bothers me then a
single thing you know what what there I
want you to change bend a little more
baby
don't break just been just bad yeah you
got a pen baby cuz you know at the end
of the day you know you know I'm sober
for a long time I quit smoking right I'm
I've never I would never cheat on you I
don't even even talk to people okay
I do a lot all right bend how would you
like me to bend more what way just been
more Oh me how you will know when you
get there right well you're like I'm
about to snap Bend maybe it's just right
now Bryce I have a question for you
in the beginning of the first six months
of your relationship did you
get her and say you know what this could
be my life partner did you have those
true feelings of like this could be it
yeah absolutely with this this girl I've
never I've had opportunity of the girls
before and I've always said no does the
first time is like there's something
more here and I wanted to pursue it and
boy living with what the girls really
difficult I or anybody not just the girl
I'm telling you living with anybody that
isn't family is very difficult yet
well and we were the same room it was
very yeah that's what living together is
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but they live with other people George I
never had a situation where we were in
the same room every day it's a small
room I there's no escape right so yeah
we're here all day every day together
you know and then right but I don't rely
on you for my happiness that's a I also
don't rely on you for a constant
companionship and I think the difference
was she's not from LA LA that was right
so he he was mostly her connection like
friendships and all of that is
everything was through him so that's
difficult because I have my own set of
friends aside from you and I can run to
them for companionship so that's that's
I think there's a very here's another
thing that helps okay is is that she has
a sister her mom people always over here
which I love because I love I love them
as they don't they're sewn just they
feel like my family in a weird way like
when I see her mom I can punch her from
behind or kick her yank family you know
or like you know we can tease like if I
have an acne on my face you're her mama
what is that wash your face you know I
mean like we joke around and I have that
it's great I've never had in this house
life this place has always been death in
this particular building you mean the
the months and years of being here
single imagine these people my I think
why that's like one of the nicest things
I've ever heard yeah being a lot you
know alone and
be now you have I have they're hugging
hugging take a look at this tiger belly
mug then [ __ ] Benny why catch your
tears and so it's like it's like you
know with even with the animals was just
life in this house so um you know it's
perfect for me
it's beautiful my walk-in toys wife
sister mothers always something going on
here and the animals yeah you're warm I
think that's all I ever wanted was you
know a partner that felt like both a
lover and family I didn't have I don't
have to make excuses for him he can be
his most authentic self and they just
really enjoy him the monster that he is
oddly enough they really love him and
they they they wrestle they [ __ ] sword
fight they do weird things and I just
I'm just a spectator to the love they
have for each other it's so I truly love
her family like I when your mom who
remember what she got the rice we have
we're [ __ ] choking on rice honestly I
mean I think about if it got if the
worst thing happened what if she died in
my house
what are you gonna outcry me now I'm
crying you I'm just saying with that
would be so terrible it would be you
would he forget terrible it would have
been a devastating life-altering event
of epic proportions that's what I think
the shock was so real you know so and I
can't say that about a lot of
girlfriends I mean I like them and stuff
right but there really is um
there really is love there you know and
that's why it's like you know when like
even like if we weren't so weird but you
won't want to say we went to Hawaii
right and we had that first meal it was
like eight hundred dollars and I paid
for it
you have to I know about to say I wanted
to but if it was any other girlfriends
family I would have been like a so split
the past so hey at least get the tip
yeah or you know or hey you got the two
orders of the calamari so you're gonna
have to pay for that part you know I
mean but with with them it's like no
this is like what I would do it for my
own parents
it felt that like comfortable and I need
to do it I need to provide you know need
to everyone has good job just saying
though in that scenario with her family
I feel like I need to provide that's so
sweet
yeah yeah just bend a little just a
little bit more Oh that'll be nice girl
just just been a little bit more no but
here's the thing what you're doing wrong
is that you can avoid those trivial
little bit confrontation no Bryce would
you say that that what this past
breakup was the biggest heartache of
your life or or have there been bigger
heartaches in the past
yeah I think each relationship I've had
about getting better at her staying I'm
getting better at understanding what I
look for a girl and what works and this
girl definitely affected me the most
absolutely now if you even if she was
the most perfect person let me tell you
living in those small confines it
wouldn't have worked either I feel like
it was a I feel like love it was my part
but also the situation was just bad
tricky it was bad yeah
tricky yeah man it's tricky I've been
bit more I agree [ __ ] you been - oh
dude I bet I'm all bended ha ha ha
I'm a circle he's a squid yeah yeah
there's no better there is no joints
they just squiddy's flexible I'm so
flexible she did introduce sturdy valley
to alani and the law I introduced it
that's true what a great color I'm not
sure I'm not down I'm not I I I'm bummed
that you're dating out dating or anybody
introducing me to a [ __ ] farming
world man
[Music]